[Music]
all right a major development in the
Clinton's server scandal you've got to
pay close attention tonight this is
going to be a blockbuster hour we here
at Fox News have obtained the draft of
James commis exoneration statement that
let Hillary Clinton off the hook as it
relates to the email server the document
shows that the term grossly negligent
was in fact changed to extreme
carelessness in two places remember
grossly negligent is the legal standard
which would have meant that Clinton
broke the law and here's the other piece
of new information in the part where
Comey was talking about foreign actors
accessing Clinton's server the word
likely accessed was removed this is
national security all of this continues
to prove that the fix was in
from the very beginning of what is a
farce of an investigation there was the
exoneration before the investigation was
anywhere near concluded and here's why
the draft statement is from May 2nd 2016
Hillary and others in her case wasn't
interviewed by the FBI until the 4th of
July weekend so how could Comey how
could this Hillary loving Trump hating
FBI agent Peter struck reach any
conclusion about Clinton's server
investigation two months before they
even interviewed her or other key people
the fix was in plain and simple we now
have the evidence and Fox News legal
analyst Gregg Jarrett says what we just
laid out could mean James Comey is
guilty of obstruction of justice that is
a crime that is a felony we'll hear from
him coming up later in the program also
tonight Judicial Watch has uncovered an
absolutely bombshell report about the
special treatment that Hillary Clinton
and her top aide Huma Abedin were given
by the Obama State Department we now
have documents that were obtained
through the Freedom of Information Act
it shows that Clinton and her top aide
they were given permission by the State
Department to remove both electronic and
physical records that they claimed will
quote personal and quote unclassified
and non recorded materials according to
Judicial Watch this includes records of
Hillary Clinton's calls her schedules
which
immediately will not be made available
to you the American people also in
addition to all this the document shows
that uma Abidine was allowed to take
five boxes of physical files from the
State Department some of which were
described as quote Muslim engagement
documents
this is beyond outrageous and it shows
that there's a different set of rules
and standards for the Clintons and their
allies a two-tiered justice system we
have been talking about and warning you
about make no mistake this shouldn't be
surprising because it is all part of a
pattern when it comes to the Clintons
the fixes in all the time fixes in
against Bernie the fixes in here the
fixes in on other issues
removing destroying documents that's now
just part of Clinton standard operating
procedures
now remember Clinton on her own 33000
subpoenaed emails from her personal
server remember she deleted him she
acid-washed them she used bleach pit and
guess what her aides were smashing
mobile devices with hammers and by the
way they gave the other mobile device to
the FBI it didn't have a SIM card it was
useless
why because Clinton claims they were
personal between her and her husband who
does an email and it was about a wedding
of funeral and yoga and grandkids
Bill Clinton doesn't use email here's
another wrinkle to the scandal it's
disturbing it needs to be investigated
according to documents that Judicial
Watch received Clinton's calls her
schedules were blocked from being made
public and were allowed to be removed
well that's interesting when you
consider this article from the AP in
August of 2016 the headline many donors
to Clinton Foundation met with her at
state and the article goes on to detail
quote at least 85 of 154 people from
private interests who met or had phone
conversations scheduled with Clinton
while she led the State Department they
all donated Turner family charity or
pledged commitments to its international
programs now and according to a review
of State Department calendars released
so far to the AP combined the 85 donors
contributed as much as a hundred and
fifty six million dollars and at least
40 donated more than
$100,000 each and 20 gave more than a
million so is that why Clinton and
Aberdeen wanted to remove records of
Hillary's calls and schedules this would
have come out in the campaign
and people would have been asking good
questions now Judicial Watch president
Tom Fenton he will be here in just a few
minutes also tonight breaking
investigative reporter Sarah Carter is
out with damning new details on this
controversial NSA surveillance program
that may have been used to collect
information on Americans without a
warrant these people not here of a US
Constitution against unreasonable search
and seizure that would be number four
Sarah Carter reporting that numerous
former intelligence law enforcement
officials are now blowing the whistle on
this potentially dangerous conduct in
the way your government is conducting
surveillance and this is getting scary
according to the report while the
officials they were concerned over a
practice that is known as reverse
targeting which quote occurs when
intelligence and law enforcement
officials use a foreign person as a
legal pretense for their intended target
an American citizen in other words
without a warrant
in other words illegal in other words no
Constitution no Fourth Amendment now
Sarah Carter will also join us at a
moment to explain how this practice may
have been used as a political weapon how
often have you heard me talk about
weaponizing our intelligence community
weaponizing the system of Justice we
have in this country dual system of
justice now also tonight we have
breaking information about how the
anti-trump pro Clinton text messages
from that FBI agent Peter struck and his
FBI lawyer girlfriend Lisa Paige were
discovered DOJ Inspector General Michael
Horowitz is now revealing that his
office requested those text messages
from government-issued cell phones of
several FBI employees that handled the
Clinton email case in this particular
case there are more tenth within 10,000
of the text messages between struck and
his girlfriend Paige well as of now 375
that's it Fox News was able to obtain
just those show a severe anti-trump Pro
Hillary Clinton bias now these text
messages include calling Trump a
human being an idiot struct in page also
disparaging and mocking Trump supporters
and that's just the start of it now
here's what is raising all kinds of red
flags and it should in August of 2016
struck texted texted I want to believe
the path you threw out for consideration
in Andy's office that there's no way he
gets elected but I'm afraid we can't
take that risk it's like an insurance
policy in the unlikely event you die
before you're forty FoxNews believes we
haven't confirmed yet that Andy in that
message is Andrew McCabe that would be
the deputy FBI director that's the same
guy whose wife Jill got seven hundred
thousand dollars in donations from
Democrats including Terry McAuliffe up
to his eyeballs in this during a 2015
Virginia State Senate run that's an
obscene amount of money for that race we
also have this exchange
now we edited out the middle of it which
contained a web link and page says and
maybe you're meant to stay where you are
because you're meant to protect the
country from that menace Wow isn't that
great they take that all upon themselves
struck replies thanks it's absolutely
true that we're both very fortunate and
of course I will try and approach it
that way I just know it will be tough at
times I can protect our country at many
levels not sure if that helps
now why would struck why would his
girlfriend page and who we now think is
Andrew McCabe need an insurance policy
against Donald Trump if he's on his way
to win the election what exactly did
that mean now Judicial Watch just
announced that it has filed a lawsuit to
gain access to all the FBI records about
the removal of struck from the Muller
investigation here's what the deal is
you the American people you deserve
answers there's a lot at stake here
there's all reeks of this deep state
we've been telling you about and their
effort to undermine a candidate that
then became president and the Wall
Street Journal is reporting that this
apparent meeting between struck page and
McCabe happened during the same time the
FBI started its counterintelligence
investigation into quote possible Trump
Rush
Tai's and as we've been telling you this
FBI agent Peter struck is tied to
everything and his FBI lawyer girlfriend
also served on Robert Muller's team
here's what we know about struck before
being demoted from molars investigation
he was a top counterintelligence
official he was the guy that actually
signed the document that kicked off the
Russian investigation
strux team also oversaw the handling of
the anti-trump dossier the Russian
propaganda when it was given to the FBI
he was in charge of the interview of
former national security adviser
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn and
this is where it gets really interesting
given structs anti-trump Pro Hillary
text messages he also played a pivotal
role in this Clinton email exoneration
so-called investigation now this
includes sitting in on Hillary's FBI
interview remember that was in July in
May they already were writing the
exoneration he was also in the room for
the interviews with key Clinton aides
Huma Abedin Cheryl Mills and this is the
most damning piece of information when
it comes to struck he's the guy he's the
one that actually changed the legal
standard language in James Comey 'he's
exoneration statement about hillary
clinton from grossly negligent to
extreme carelessness
well that allowed hillary clinton to get
out of jail free card that allowed the
fix to be in from the get-go even though
we know she broke the law what in god's
name is robert muller thinking to have
ever put together this abusively bias
this corrupt FBI agent and so many other
people that have agendas on his
so-called investigative team Muller
claims to have Oh impeccable integrity a
sterling reputation well why would
anybody allow that to happen and then
again that all seems to make sense when
you consider all the Democratic donors
that Mullen has hand-picked to be part
of the investigation
now these investigators have given over
15 grand in cash to Democrats including
Barack Obama and you guessed it Hillary
Clinton this one donated to a Republican
and none of them gave any money to the
Trump campaign this entire investigation
corrupt to its core it has now become a
witch-hunt and it's now the time where
jeff sessions needs to do his job it's
time for you the American people to
understand this according to a new poll
54% say robert muller has a conflict of
interest because of his friendship
he's BFF with james comey and as we've
been telling you there these two are
best friends and as Fox News legal
analyst Gregg Jarrett has pointed out on
many an occasion their relationship
could also actually be a violation of
the law
calling Attorney General sessions where
are you
step up and do your job